here now with more about an hour just
before this happened country music
superstars longtime friend of mine John
Ritchie was on with Big and Rich and
also reporting artist kaya Jones John
you big and rich always honors the
military in your shows little over an
hour before all of this went down you
took to the stage you honor the military
you invite people on take it from there
what do you what do you ask the audience
to do because I've gotten the video and
I'm going to show it in a second so
every show that we do and this has been
now for over a thousand concerts in a
row big Kenny and I like to invite up
active duty and veterans and sometimes
first responders as well we'll bring
them up on stage and we'll read their
names we'll read where they served when
they serve what their job is in that
town in that community and then we hand
the microphone over to them and let them
speak to the audience and then we always
leave the entire crowd in and god bless
america
so last night we continued that
tradition and did it again and Shawn you
look out there and there's 22,000 people
who had come in from Southern California
from Arizona from Nevada there were
people there from Canada there were
people there from Tennessee there were
people there from all over the United
States and North America singing god
Bless America at the top of their lungs
with their phones held high with the
lights on celebrating freedom and the
ability to live as Americans and sing
together in unity it was it's always a
huge thing to see that kind of unity
when everybody can sing the words
together of course not everybody in the
audience that agrees with each other but
we all agree that we're Americans that
we sing together so that happened and
not not not long after that you know the
exact 180 of this happened as that
carnage began to take place and and
khaya just so happened that you were on
the stage with John big Kenney and John
Rich at the time big and rich
let me show just some of this to the
audience so they can actually see it and
hear it for themselves
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
pretty amazing moment at all these
concerts John we've been friends forever
Caillou got to participate in that last
night tell us what that was like for you
it was magical it was every color creed
religion everyone was coming together it
was unity and the guys were bringing
everyone together and we had veterans on
stage and it was you know paying homage
to them and what they do for our nation
and to think that moments later people
were gunned down I mean it could have
been big Kenny it could have been John
Rich it could have been myself or those
veterans that were attacked yeah you
know John I don't want to drag in in the
politics of all this this isn't when
people sing god bless america we love
our country
you know nobody that goes to your
concerts you know I'm showing the video
now of although you know the nearly
30,000 people holding up their cell
phones in unison there those are
Americans you know I've been on the road
when Lee Greenwood says it sings god
bless the USA look at that every single
person has the light on it's not
Democrat Republican liberal or
conservative and I you know a lawyer for
CBS oh I have no sympathy for Vegas
victims they're probably Republicans let
me just play this a little bit listen
let the audience take this in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
John I'm that's an hour before this
happened on how it just it makes you
want to ball I mean I got goose finds
out it really just I mean I was standing
there singing it you know I was watching
that happen it's it's you know when
people try to politicize this kind of
stuff it to me it's just so disgusting
to hear that you know that's America
standing in that crowd
that's not one party or another party
when you play music we don't play music
for this this group or that group we
play music for anybody that wants to
come listen to it and I think it's just
a really really terrible comment for
anybody to say something like that you
see in that audience right there like I
said people from all over the United
States
all joining in together and singing and
by the way there's one young man I want
to say his name on your program a young
kid from Sandy Big Sandy Tennessee his
name is Sonny and he was in his mid-20s
he came to the Big & Rich show first
time he'd been to a big concert like
this and he was one of the very first
casualties we know we met his shook his
hand and met him in the meet and greet
and you know man it's this is this is an
this is it's it's something so terrible
you almost can't digest what this really
is but at least it's it people should be
able to hold their tongues for a while
and not disrespect all these people that
have lost their lives and that are now
fighting for their lives in the
hospitals we got no time for that
we really don't not we don't even know
the outcome for a lot of these families
Kyle we're going to give you a last for
a wiki I still in getting goosebumps all
over looking at that video heartbreaking
that story that Kenny just told it's
intense and you know what less guns
don't equal less terrorists bottom line
it's not the time or the place
honor the dead respect the dead pay a
march to them today it's about them
today it's not about the shooter it's
not about a gun
not about politics it's about them I
have a tweet from a teacher pray that
only trump cards die seriously
so we deserve to die you don't have a so
we deserve to get shot because we voted
for Trump is that what the is your human
soul to tweet that out all right you're
both good friends that was a amazing
moment an hour before unbelievable